this is boris johnson arriving
on the world stage and center stage as
host of this crucial global summit
these the men and women charged with
shaping the world recovery from a
devastating global pandemic
this fast coming together of these
leaders and a moment to strengthen and
build
alliances thank you very much
but the us uk relationship not the only
one that could be special
a new us president a new opportunity for
the leaders gathered here
look who's taking note and chair in the
most significant g7 in several
years decisions made around this table
could determine whether we beat this
virus
or not it is genuinely wonderful
to see everybody in person i can't tell
you what a difference it makes we've all
been going through
the most wretched uh pandemic
i think that is what the people of the
uh
of our countries now want us to to focus
on they want us
to be sure that we're beating the
pandemic together
and discussing how we'll never
have a repeat of what we've seen but
also that we're building back
better together and building that
greener
and building that pharah and building
back more
equal ambitions to accelerate vaccine
roll out to poorer nations
efforts to close the yawning gap in
educational opportunities for women and
girls
and to tackle another threat to humanity
and the planet
climate change united by those common
goals
but there are political differences and
tensions
this team eu snapshot a signal to boris
johnson
if he wants this group as allies their
brexit deal
must be respected
but tensions over northern ireland
remain and the uk government is not
rolling over yet
we want a flexible pragmatic approach
that deals with the equities on both
sides
but for that to happen the eu must be
less purist more pragmatic and more
flexible
in the implementation of it the ball is
very much in the eu's court in relation
to that
in any other year these tensions between
the uk
and the eu would threaten to overshadow
even derail a summit like this
and i am told that eu leaders will raise
the matter of northern ireland privately
with the pm but this is no normal year
this is a very particular
unique year it's the first gathering
since the pandemic
began the fast of the biden
administration and after all that has
gone wrong in recent years
there's a real will here to put things
right
so that's a huge opportunity and it's
fallen straight into boris johnson's lap
as one delegate here said to me he's the
luckiest politician
alive in recent times luck has felt in
short supply
but these leaders have a chance to
change the fortunes of not just their
own people
but of all people the whole world waits
to see if they can offer more
than talk beth rigby's sky news cornwall